this show sucks man I love you but this
is brutal
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we welcome back comedian Eric
Andre his first ever stand-up special
legalized everything is available now
keep an eye out as well for his
hidden-camera comedy bad trip which is
likewise set to release on Netflix and
of course the Eric Andre show season 5
an Adult Swim later this year Eric Andre
welcome back to the show thank you for
having me back may be about me it may be
available out of curiosity is your
relationship with Hot Sauce changed at
all since you did hot ones like four
years ago
I feel braver now I having gone through
that it was like a rite of passage I
never had anything that hot in my life
nor haven't had anything that hot ever
since but it made me feel like okay it's
it's very hard but it's possible you
know I didn't understand at the time the
weight of that day and that moment it's
kind of like followed me around even to
this day people will scream at me on the
street to nosh a where you at how has it
been like for you
well Tanaka and I are now officially
married and we're having her we're
having a baby girl this August it's been
cool I didn't realize how popular your
show was until I did it people love it
I'm so I'm so ready
oh my god that's hot that's not not ha
that's one uh-huh by like four I'm very
[ __ ] all right sure
[Music]
so I want to start by talking to you
about your special legalized everything
which is getting a lot of positive press
from nailing the zeitgeist with a lot of
bits even though it was taped
pre-pandemic did having it takes on a
shell on deck during quarantine feel
like a superpower as a comedian like you
had an ace in the hole oh my god
understand thank God I didn't tour this
year filming this year like scheduled to
film it this year I totally left out
blind luck I did not predict the
coronavirus it's good it's hot but it's
good how important is a stand-ups height
music and why did you choose big Freitas
Third Ward bounce for this one I filmed
in New Orleans so I wanted a New Orleans
artist and big Freitas music is just so
bombastic and powerful and cinematic I'm
such a big free to fan we had her on the
Eric Andre show this upcoming season so
it was a no-brainer do I continue eating
do I just go on do I move on myself or
do you queue me you know we're walking
down this road together but now is the
time to move on to the second wing which
is the steel ok ok Jaguar how the pinata
[Music]
that's a bad idea right it's a that's a
lot of sauce Eric after my hot ones I'm
I [ __ ] molten lava for like two days
I'll you girly await the update this
time uh-huh I'll email you from Mike
Tojo toilet so in 2019 year clown
alter-ego blarf released his debut album
cease-and-desist which features an
interlude from that famous role-model
interview between Katie Couric and Lil
Wayne I don't know what you're talking
about man I have nothing to do that guy
I don't know who that guy is I don't
know who the [ __ ] he is but a challenges
[ __ ] legal team to come at me guns
blazing as someone who grew up listening
to hip-hop do you miss the comedic
sketches that used to serve as a kind of
connective tissue between songs hell no
that was like a fast-forward exercise
and I understand that [ __ ] on cassette
tape and just hearing guys just roast
each other and [ __ ] I was just like
I have one red band album website the
suspensions like 45 minutes in between
you so what are we doing here
red man is one of the funnies where I
love red man
hopefully he wasn't takeout in and so I
love love love madman I actually got
arrested when I was 18 years old seeing
him live at UM in Miami at the Miami
Heat amphitheater would they charge you
with marijuana
fold a round and Fred's note are these
the same sauce blended last night so the
operations a little bit more
sophisticated now back when you run the
show we were just kind of throwing darts
and then we've since kind of gotten our
[ __ ] together as far as hot sauce
creation goes but to bomb which I think
was your number eight when you when you
were there we haven't found the sauce
that's quite like it so we've cut that
in so that's a sauce that you've had
before these are like sleeper sleeper
hits my nose is running they sneak up on
you
I can't even know that one snuck up on
me
so I once heard Ashton Kutcher make the
point that a show like Punk'd is more a
study of human nature than it is like
candid camera with celebrities is doing
the Eric Andre show taught you anything
about human fallibility and tense
situations mmm makes me in less cynical
actually people are like really willing
to help each other out when they're not
when they're presented with them odd
situation there's also this YouTube
phenomenon of channels passing off
obviously fake pranks is real does that
bother you like do you think there needs
to be a sense of ethics in the prank
genre I do personally I'm in situ their
own but like to me there's absolutely no
point unless you're doing it for real
there's no stakes it defeats the purpose
it's completely pointless all right Eric
how is that one we're still in a
manageable place how's the build okay
it's got a little bit of a lingering
effect and they all have a cumulative
effect so but it's okay these first
three are like they're they're realistic
[Music]
I'm I am I have a sense this one's a
[ __ ]
this is hotter hotter than L correct
[Music]
okay this one's gonna suck I can tell ya
it's got a good flavor though couple of
tang to it so is anyone who follows your
nose you're always up for a good time
and it seems like you really been
exploring the world of cocktails lately
where do you fall in the great debate of
mixologist versus bartender do you think
there's actually a difference I actually
think the tastiest drinks are the simple
ones but the real real make-or-break for
me is if you're using fresh-squeezed
juice or pre-made juice that is such a
making a breagan if you're not fresh
squeezing that lime right before you
make that drink get the [ __ ] out my face
cuz that's the stuff that gives you the
hangover the premade sugary high
fructose corn syrup mixes they just made
that juice pineapple juice watermelon
juice as long as they make it that at
least that day then they're a good
bartender what's been your proudest
cocktail creation during quarantine and
can you tell us how to make it mmm I
just made one call the yellows number
two and it's a yellow pepper juice it's
mezcal one and a half ounces of mezcal
and one and a half ounces of yellow
pepper juice a half an ounce of yellow
chartreuse half an ounce of simple syrup
half an ounce of lemon juice shake it
strain and put in a rocks glass and put
smoked salt and a chargesheet dill
pepper as the garnish oh [ __ ]
[Music]
that one is good than what I'm reacting
ha ha - should I refrigerate these after
opening how long will they last in the
fridge a long time months long time
hot sauce lasts not like not like
yourself maybe you could get a year out
of it that vinegar oh my god oh yeah
yeah so tell me about this one so this
is Lowe's calientes Rojo it's like oh
[Music]
it's delicious you like that one
mmm not about to kick my ass but every
bite
Oh Garrett we have a recurring segment
on our show called explain that Graham
where do a deep dive on I guess
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so I'll show you the
picture you just tell me the bigger
story and we have a meet your heroes
theme today for Eric Andre okay I love
that you tell me right when this place
is like kicking my [ __ ] ass you do
this whole worthy explanation and I'm
like I'm not gonna like puke State first
things first it's you with Johnny
Knoxville what is it about jackass that
made it such a brilliant show there
likeable you root for them they're not
mean-spirited they are
never said to humor about themselves oh
my god what's torture and then whatever
thrown up on the show you know I'm not
in front of me but I like people have
bailed for the restroom with urgency
before as a student of the game
what makes Sacha Baron Cohen such a
master of the craft of satire there's a
genius
he's got like a 180 IQ he's operating at
a higher frequency he's got a definitely
[ __ ] up please pull yourself I love
situations how are you not in pain the
[ __ ] man well I think out of here I
think I just I know what to expect
Eric you know when when you and me met
for the first time we hadn't done that
many episodes and now we're like over
200 episodes I've had lots of practice
you got your own game show right yeah
yeah and I don't even have to eat on
that one
how you gonna film it in covin you know
what's nice about game shows we shot
like the whole years worth like in ten
days back in December so you live it on
easy street man see that flat-screen you
got a new flat-screen
I'm proud of you man
[Music]
suck my [ __ ] sideways this is hot
[Laughter]
[Music]
careful I'm the big pores here in the
back half Erik I think yes why what did
Coolio do again money I he let the
bravado get to him and on the last wing
he popped the sauce and then emptied it
onto the wing clean with a poker face
and then it's like a time bomb when I'm
inside his body suicide
alright there's a little dabble right
these are kind of dangerous right yeah
[Music]
so with hot ones we put a lot of pride
into trying to extend for our guests and
put together the best possible version
of a career spanning interview but I
feel like doing a purposefully bad
interview probably takes even more prep
[Music]
[Music]
this just sucks man huh I love you but
this is brutal
are there certain elements or mechanics
that make a bad interview funny to you
I'm glad you asked
[Music]
yeah the more awkward they are I'm more
funny you are I think I would get worse
at this wage do you have a lasting
memory of going toe to toe with an art
bar the internet loves unpackage that
one oh my love learn where everybody
thought I was like being mean to but I
love that guy beat his research skills
it's unmatched
he's prolific he's interviewed everyone
and he gets access to everyone I have
such admiration for him I was harassing
him to help us with season 5 and help us
like do like Private Eye investigative
work for the guests to find a
deep-penetration he refused to do it
he was very standoffish she didn't want
anything to do with me I was really
heartbroken man all right you're doing
great only only a few more delegate ah
yes you are Eric Schadt you gotta fix
this three how youporn offend you I'm
fine you're gonna keep it classy you
would get me to to the Bellas thing
Jesus Greg I'm sorry dumb I'm sorry Dom
first our favor I'd like to apologize on
his behalf
okay there's gonna suck Wow are you
telling it really gonna suck they have a
specific taste it's like a metallic yeah
it actually doesn't taste good that hot
this is the ones on them
oh my god so last time you're on the
show you talked about how your
personality off-camera is a lot less
extreme than people would expect
describing yourself as sedated and out
of it and saying that you jog and eat
salads do you still meditate twice a day
I sure do
[Music]
I'm gonna cry
cause we the [ __ ] down of action uh none
of them were [ __ ] Delilah I know that
you're a big Michael Pollan fan is there
anything you found fascinating about his
recent deep dive into the world of
psychedelics never do toad better
together
[Music]
because the only what he will repeat
that he had no sets himself he had no
sense of what the matter was
do you feel like you're tripping right
now
I'm in a different place I can't do two
Baba
[Music]
if I do it this copy what drop
yeah very light very light air I can't
believe the water is it worse than you
remember is worse I remember it's a
dollar wha a bit of state of panic
I love the heaters l believe that come
out of your show I think you might make
some of your own today oh my god it's so
funny it's so funny
what was he reacting to which sauce this
one why did you keep this one why did
this stand the test of time because
that's how you get the interest Alba me
oh my god its death how did I agree to
do this again save majors this hate me
for myself think how it feels like when
you're getting drunk at the bar your
friends are needing more and more shots
and that last shot you take they're like
I keep no more and then see another shot
coming
sorry mad dog over-served okay two drops
this one's for aegis of up maybe we all
one day have the same sized penis
[Music]
so as we mentioned your Netflix special
is titled legalized everything but what
I want to know on this wing is do you
really mean it this is a brand new
segment that we're calling legalize it
so I'll hit you with some crazy regional
laws we've researched on the internet
and you just tell me whether or not you
should you would legalize them and why
and watch it in Washington state killing
Bigfoot's punishable by up to five years
in prison
hunting Bigfoot legalize it good god
[Music]
don't touch your eyes or your face here
okay what is the one in Washington state
killing Bigfoot is punishable by up to
five years in prison
would you legalize hunting Bigfoot sure
whatever you want
taking us for the tour I'm gonna throw
up
[Music]
I bought milk of magnesia because I was
pulling a lot of protests and I didn't
want to get cheered gastro pepper
sprayed and if I did I was going to pour
tea my eyes but now you found another
use yeah I'm not the biggest [ __ ] dude
hey Eric Eric how about this let's just
let's let's slow it down let's slow it
down no need to keep pushing forward
you've already done it before you know
what I mean it's not like it's not like
there's that much at stake here let's
just let's just slow it down okay
no need to eat any more no need to eat
any more don't eat any more here no
there's no room left in my stomach ma'am
[Music]
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] real dude Eric it's
okay Eric it's okay you know what it was
it was it was a fun it was I'm happy
that we connected over the over the zoom
here over the QuickTime here it's gonna
be great I saw the special it's really
funny I hope everybody who's watching
now goes out and watch it on Netflix
Eric Andre season five later this year
and then of course bad trip on Netflix
keep an eye out it's good to see you
Eric best of luck I hope you recover
soon okay buddy thanks man I appreciate
it I'll talk to you soon
all right peace Eric these
sorry I got pepper-sprayed dude it's
like I got sprayed by a skunk
oh honey milk of magnesia do not hey
what's going on hot ones fans this is
Sean Evans checking in with one camera
guy how you doing Steven you good
Stevens good there's no one else in this
building except for the two of us it is
locked down over here but you know what
the pepper dome is open for all new
episodes of hot ones the game show
Tuesday's on truTV the pepper dome
see you there if you dare
[Music]